[APPLAUSE]
JOSHUA PARTLOW:
Thanks very much.
Good morning, everybody.
It's great to be here.
My name is Josh.
Like he said, I'm with
the Washington Post.
I've been a reporter, a foreign
correspondent for the Post
for about 10 years now.
I've been based in
Iraq, in Brazil,
and currently living in Mexico.
I had been in Rio
de Janeiro in 2009
and had a great, great place
a couple blocks from the beach
and my boss asked me to help out
very temporarily in Afghanistan
for two months and cover an
election for Hamid Karzai's
second term.
And I thought it was going
to be just a brief stay,
and I ended up spending
five years on and off
in Afghanistan, and it became
a really big part of my life.
I made a lot of lifelong
friends there in that situation.
And so I'm really thrilled
to be here and excited.
This book's been a long
time coming for me.
I've been working
on it for a while.
And when I got there as
a reporter for the Post,
I had been in Iraq for a
couple years in 2006 and 2007.
And the violence there and
the combat was really-- I
mean, it was
everywhere in Baghdad.
There were car bombs and
suicide bombings every day.
And it was the
kind of thing where
we were living hunkered
down and just escaping
for an hour or to do interviews
and coming back to the house
and just trying to
stay safe mostly.
And what I found in Afghanistan
was a lot different than that,
particularly in Kabul,
the capital city.
It was much safer, basically.
You could get around.
You could live a normal life.
The war was mostly out
in the countryside,
in the rural areas.
The Taliban was involved
in sabotage and hit and run
attacks and this low level
of insurgent violence.
And so what I found myself
writing about more and more
was the political scandals
that were engulfing the United
States and the Afghan government
over there, whether it
was some bribery scandal
at the Ministry of Mines
or the US, the DEA
investigators and the FBI
going after President
Karzai's brother,
trying to uncover his
business dealings,
or the fights between the
US Ambassador and President
Karzai.
And so I guess I
found being there
that what seemed
to be determining
the course of the war
was less the combat
and more of these
political struggles.
And the US military was
fighting several wars at once.
They were fighting the Taliban
on the ground in these far off,
distant villages, and they were
fighting the Afghan government
that we had helped set up and
we had empowered over a decade.
And they were also fighting
within the themselves.
The military, and the State
Department, and the CIA all
had different strategies
of what to do.
So the book that I
wrote is basically
a story of those other wars
and how wherever you looked,
there was a Karzai in
the middle of them.
Whether it was we were
trying to figure out
how to deal with the
warlords and there
was Ahmed Wali Karzai, who was
the president's half-brother,
and he was the kingpin
figure in Kandahar
who was larger than
life and was accused
of presiding over the drug
trade in southern Afghanistan.
And when we were
trying to figure out
how to make this government into
more like a Western democracy,
Mahmoud Karzai,
the other brother,
was involved in banking scandals
and these corruption issues.
In the book, I try
to explain basically
some of the things,
some of the areas
where I think the United States
went wrong in Afghanistan,
and how we tried to change a
little bit too much about how
the Afghan government functioned
and how we didn't really
understand or we weren't
really honest with ourselves
about who we were fighting.
So just to get a
sense of the writing,
I was going to read
a very small portion.
This takes place when Ahmed Wali
Karzai has just been killed.
And he was the
president's half-brother,
and he was murdered
in the summer of 2011,
and he had been the glue that
held the family together.
And when he was murdered by
one of his closest associates,
it fractured the family
and sent everybody
fighting over the
business empire
and trying to maintain
the political stability.
So it's a key moment in
the story of the family.
And it took place
in a village called
Karz, which is the president's
home village, which
is near Kandahar.
And it's a little small
town, grape-growing area.
And the family
cemetery is there.
His father and his grandfather
were all buried there,
dozens of Karzais.
And one of the cousins
who had been selling
car loans in
suburban Virginia and
then had moved back to
Afghanistan after 2001
and had opened a
private security company
and is making millions of
dollars from the US government,
he had built a giant mansion
in the middle of the town
where he had a private
zoo and lions and tigers,
an arena for dogfighting.
So that is the setting of
where this takes place.
So I'm waiting on the road
for the funeral procession
to come down to the cemetery
and there's military
all around the area.
So what came down the road
was a group of men carrying
bamboo broom sticks, then a
man pushing a wheelbarrow,
a guy toting a shovel,
and four policemen
in mismatched shoes and white
cruise ship captains' hats.
I wondered if maybe I
was once again too late.
Then a procession of men, 20
abreast and filling the road,
came into view.
They wore turbans, and
blazers, and sandals,
and wristwatches that
glinted in the sunlight, row
after unsmiling row.
The procession swept
by and through us
and we fell in among them,
following the surging crowd
through the village
until we came
to a grove of eucalyptus
trees ringed by a white metal
fence topped with arrow
shaped spikes that surrounded
the Karzai family cemetery.
We entered through the gate.
Across the cemetery grounds,
dozens of humble headstones
marked the graves
of lesser Karzais.
In the center stood
a small, open air,
domed mausoleum,
an inner sanctum
reserved for family royalty.
The president's father,
Abdul Ahad Karzai,
a former parliament member
and leader of the Popalzais,
was buried there, as
was his grandfather,
another tribal Han,
Khair Muhammad.
That morning, men
from the village
had used picks and shovels
to pierce its marble floor
and dig the grave where
Ahmed Wali lay in the dirt
under a white sheet.
The crowd surged
around the open grave.
Shouting and jostling,
mourners pushed toward it,
six and seven men deep.
Among them where
many Popalzais who
lived in the area and
surrounding villages.
There were also dignitaries
who had flown in
from Kabul the night before.
I recognized cabinet
ministers, army generals,
and provincial
governors sweating
in their suits and uniforms.
People were wailing and crying.
Security guards in
black bulletproof vests
with curly cords tucked
behind their ears tried
in vain to keep control,
screaming and shoving people
back from the lip.
Then the sound of
rotor blades rose
above the din and the
US military Blackhawk
helicopter touched down
in a plume of dust.
The president had arrived.
Hamid Karzai,
looking wan, pushed
through the tangle of bodies and
stood at the edge of the grave.
He wore a simple white
tunic and a dark vest.
He looked down into the
hole and said nothing.
I could see he was crying.
For a second, the
scene seemed to freeze,
bodies teetering over the
pit, all eyes trained on him.
Then he dropped into the grave.
He knelt to kiss his
murdered brother,
and the crowd
closed in over him,
breaking like water
through a dam.
People enveloped him in a
tangle of interlocking limbs.
He stayed down there, out
of sight, under the bodies,
for what seemed like
minutes, amid the keening
moan of the crowd.
Then the bodies
parted and he rose
from the ground, hoisted
up and out of the grave
by the men around him.
He walked quickly through them,
out through the cemetery gate
to his waiting convoy, and
drove off without saying a word.
A group of men lowered a
concrete slab over the corpse
and shoveled in dirt.
When they had filled
the grave, they
pressed in two saplings,
one at either end,
and tied them together
with pink ribbon.
Almost everyone had dispersed
by the time it was done.
So this was just a little
scene of the cemetery there.
So the book goes on from
there, tracing, basically,
the election in
2009 that I first
observed and the final election,
when Karzai left power,
in 2014.
And I think it's a story about
how the United States really
went out of their
way to build up
these people in all
sorts of different ways,
from politically supporting
the president to giving--
one of the brothers
on the CIA payroll.
Another one received loans
from the US government
for some of his
business projects.
And then, by the
end of their arc,
they had become the
enemies of the US
and really were at the center
of a lot of the conflicts we had
and the trouble we
had in Afghanistan.
So I'd be happy to
take any questions you
have about the book or
Afghanistan in general.
AUDIENCE: What are
they up to today?
JOSHUA PARTLOW:
So the president,
he left office peacefully.
There was a lot of
speculation leading up to 2014
that he would try to
change the constitution
and stay in power indefinitely.
But he accepted the popular
vote and he's now living
a few blocks from the palace.
But he's still very
involved in politics
and he's meeting with leaders,
tribal leaders, every day.
And his critics
speculate that he's
trying to scheme
and return to power,
because the current
government is pretty weak
and is very fragile right now.
So there's a lot of concern,
or there's a lot of suspicion
that he will be back
in the spotlight again.
Because the situation
in Afghanistan
right now is a lot worse
than even when I was there.
In 2014, the Taliban are
stronger than they used to be.
They control a lot of
areas around the country.
The government is weaker than it
used to be and is very fragile.
The US still has
10,000 soldiers there,
so we still have
quite a footprint,
but we're more in
an advisory role.
So everyone's trying to keep
it from collapsing right now,
is the main issue.
AUDIENCE: So with the
benefit of hindsight,
what are some of
the things that you
think maybe could have
been done differently
or should have been done
differently, looking back
over how much
support the US gave
to the Karzais and the
politics that came out of that?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: I mean,
I think one of the things
is we could've managed
our expectations better
about what was possible to
be changed in Afghanistan.
And this was a country where
before 2001 the colleagues,
the Afghan colleagues
I worked with there,
they would have to drive
for hours to Pakistan
if they wanted to
make a phone call.
And then the
government ministries,
they don't have electricity.
People don't have computers.
They were starting from
absolute zero when this started.
And we poured in billions
and billions of dollars
into this country
to try to make it--
I think the
expectation was almost
that we could make it a modern,
Western, functioning democracy.
So when that wasn't
happening, and there
was a lot of people
stealing this aid money,
it became an obsession
for the United States,
and they launched
these investigations
into why this
corruption was happening
and who was stealing this money.
And that, I think, ended up
undermining their relations
with the Karzai
government in a huge way,
and was not really necessary,
I think, in the long run.
So that was one thing.
I think that we were not
also honest with ourselves
about the enemy.
When President Obama would
talk about Afghanistan,
he would talk about Al Qaeda
and the threat from Al Qaeda
and we have to make this not
a sanctuary for terrorism
anymore.
But when I was working
in Afghanistan,
I hardly saw-- no one
would talk about Al Qaeda.
It was all about the Taliban.
For the commanders on the
ground, for the diplomats
it was not much of a concern.
So the Afghan Taliban, from what
I learned and what I saw there,
was interested in controlling
Afghanistan and controlling
the politics, being involved
in the politics of Afghanistan
but didn't have international
terrorism ambitions
for the most part.
And so President Karzai's
criticism of United States
were the Americans are
attacking Afghan homes,
or they're bombing Afghan homes,
or killing Afghan civilians,
or bringing dogs
into their houses.
That really resonated with
people because, I think,
a lot of people were
really upset about the US
military presence there.
And we didn't really acknowledge
the extent of that discontent
among Afghans.
AUDIENCE: Why did
the US pick Karzai?
And do you think the outcome
could have been different
if they'd gone
with somebody else?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah, well,
he was a default candidate
in a lot of ways.
I mean, there were some
other very prominent
charismatic Afghans around 2001.
Two of them got killed right in
the days either prior or days
just after September 11.
He was a moderate
English-speaking Pashtun
from the majority
ethnic group there.
And he was a known entity
among US diplomats.
He had lived in Pakistan
as an exile for many years,
and he had been involved
in the Afghan resistance
to the Soviet
occupation in the '80s.
So he was somebody who
had rather moderate views.
He was not a warlord.
He didn't have
blood on his hands.
And so I think that he was
acceptable to the United States
for that reason.
He was also acceptable to the
other factions in Afghanistan,
the other ethnic groups, the
other warlords and commanders.
So he was the least offensive
choice to a lot of people,
I think.
I mean, whether it would
have been different
with someone else,
I mean, I really
wonder if it had been
different with someone else.
I mean, now there's a different
president in Afghanistan,
and he's having a
hard time keeping
this coalition of
ethnic groups together,
and the government's more
divided than it was before.
So I think what his
great skill was,
was he was a natural
politician and he embraced
the tribal customs of
Afghan politics, where
you get together and
you sit and hundreds
of villages come
in for hours on end
and talked about
their complaints.
The farmers talk about their
complaints from the village
and he hears these
people, and that's
where he's getting his
ground understanding
of the war in Afghanistan,
from these people that
are coming into the
palace by the tens
and hundreds every day.
And that time, those hours
in the lunch or at dinner
late at night that he
spent with these people,
he loved that aspect
of Afghan politics.
And he was very good at keeping
his-- I think his main goal was
keeping the broad
coalition together,
even if he's turning a blind
eye to people stealing money.
So I think his legacy,
part of his legacy,
will be that he kept Afghanistan
from descending further
into civil war.
And that was a very
real possibility
all throughout this
last 15 years there.
I mean, there is
obviously a war going on,
and it's still violent, and
refugees are flowing out
of Afghanistan
now at high rates,
and Afghan security forces
are dying in greater numbers
than they ever have.
So this is by no means
a victory of any means.
I describe it as a tragedy
in the title of the book.
But you talk to the
diplomats who worked with him
and the commanders who worked
with him, and a lot of them
will say he was probably
the best choice for the time
and place.
In the research for
this book, I ended up
developing more respect
for him, I guess,
than I had initially
expected to have.
I saw him, when I first got
there, as a bit unhinged.
I mean, he's this
emotional guy who
was crying in public about
the tragedy of his country.
And just he seemed
like a guy who
was biting the
hand that fed him,
and he's a puppet president
essentially propped up
by the United
States and yet he's
spending all this time
criticizing every action.
But I came to think that
he was genuinely concerned
about the welfare of the
Afghan people and was
and was being a critic at a
time when-- and was really
standing up to what he saw
as a military strategy that
wasn't working.
AUDIENCE: After the US
withdraws 10,000 troops,
do you see the
current Afghanistan
government being able to
survive without US support?
And if it does disintegrate,
which groups do you think
are going to rise to
power in Afghanistan?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah,
it's a great question.
It's the key question right now.
I was reading today there was
an estimate that the government.
It thinks it controls
about 60% of Afghanistan.
So there's 2/3 of the
country that it does control.
The Taliban is
surrounding Lashkar Gah
in Helmand province, which is
a province tens of thousands,
maybe more, US
soldiers have fought.
And many died there, trying
to defend these villages
and establish the Afghan
government in these areas.
And so that's reverted
almost completely
to Taliban control,
which for people
who were living and working
in Afghanistan at the time
I was, to see that
change is stunning.
That's where billions and
billions of dollars were spent
and thousands of lives
were lost defending
the Afghan government.
And it's also the key
terrain for the Taliban.
So that's another
northern city, Kunduz,
is in a similar predicament.
So without any US
troops, I think
these are all the reasons why
President Obama has delayed
the withdrawal of troops.
And we were supposed to be
completely out of the country
by now, but there's
still 10,000 people.
But I think that unless the
US cuts off all funding, which
I don't think
anyone is proposing,
they're still paying probably
$10 to $20 billion a year
for the Afghan
security forces, I
think the ability
is probably there
to protect the major cities.
But in the long
run, I think there
is going to have to be a
political accommodation
with the Taliban of some sort.
I mean, if they come in, if they
militarily conquer Afghanistan
again and are ruling again like
they did before 2001-- I mean,
it depends on their
internal politics,
then, of whether they want to
invite in ISIS in a big way,
or some of these other groups.
I think one thing about
the Afghan Taliban
that I learned was
that they have learned
a lesson from September 11,
and they lost their country
because they were
supporting Al Qaeda
and allowing Al Qaeda
to be in their country.
So I think that it
doesn't necessarily
follow for me that if
the Taliban regains power
completely or partially
that they'll welcome back
in a big way some of these more
extreme Islamic terror groups.
AUDIENCE: Based on your
experience in Afghanistan
during this period,
what do you foresee
in the future of US involvement
in the region [INAUDIBLE]
Afghanistan?
And do you have any
policy recommendations
for the next president
based on that?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah.
It's interesting.
I mean, one recommendation
for both the candidates
or the next president would be
to talk about Afghanistan more.
I mean, there was an interesting
piece in the New York Times
the other day about how
neither candidate has really
raised it as an issue.
And I mean, it's
clear in one sense.
There's not a lot to gain
from focusing on a 15-year war
that nobody has a
good solution for.
But yeah, I think
when I was there,
when there was a surge of
some 100,000 American troops
and we were really militarily
trying to defeat the Taliban,
I think there could have been
more effort made in the peace
negotiations.
The thought at the
time was that we
have to hammer them
into submission
and basically they'll only
negotiate if they're losing
or fear they're losing.
And they've managed to
weather that situation.
I think the current president
of Afghanistan and President
Karzai as well, they made
overtures to the Taliban.
They tried to get those
peace talks going,
but ultimately, that
dialogue is going
to be the only avenue
out of this endless war.
So that would be the focus
if I was running this thing.
AUDIENCE: If the
Afghanistan government
decides to sign a peace deal
with the Taliban government,
do you foresee the US stopping
its aid towards Afghanistan?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: That's
a great question.
I don't think-- it
depends on, I guess,
the actions of the Taliban.
I mean, if they welcome
in ISIS or help groups
with international
terrorist goals,
I'm sure there will be
some shift in the policy.
But I think American
officials would
welcome Taliban participation
in the government.
As long ago as 2014 and the
run up to that election,
there was a lot of talk
about Taliban candidates,
at least on the local level,
for district governorships
or provincial governorships.
Maybe not like in
the FARC in Colombia,
where now they're actually in
an official process of trying
to turn the rebel group into
political candidates, where
you're campaigning under
the banner of the FARC,
but at least people who are
sympathetic to the Taliban, who
would be known as
representing their interests,
as welcome candidates.
And I guess, going back to
mistakes, early in the war,
there was a blanket
policy, basically,
in Afghanistan that
the Taliban couldn't
participate in politics.
I mean, much the
same way we disbanded
the Iraqi Army in Baghdad
and cleaned out Saddamists,
and those people ended
up joining the insurgency
and fighting against
us for years.
I think most Afghans that I
met, including in government,
have a much more nuanced
view of the Taliban
as other Afghan actors
and politicians,
and they see a place for them
in the Afghan political debate
about what's important.
So I don't foresee
them being excluded
in a big way in the future.
AUDIENCE: Last
question for me, sorry.
The opinion polls from Afghanis,
do they want America still
to be involved in Afghanistan?
And the second thing, women's
rights in Afghanistan,
have women's rights
been promoted
since the US has been there?
And do you see this change being
sustained after America leaves?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah,
on that question,
I think there have been
very tangible changes
for the situation for women
in Afghanistan since 2001.
I mean, living under the Taliban
as a woman sounds like it
was a brutal experience.
But it's still an extremely
conservative place,
and the treatment of women was
something that, as a foreigner,
as an American, that was the
hardest thing about being
in Afghanistan was seeing
women treated, essentially
as property and
kept in their homes.
I mean, on certain
levels, there's
a lot more access to public
life than there was in the past.
I mean, there's plenty of
women in the Afghan parliament
in positions of power, many
more than there were before.
So that's tangible progress.
More women are going to school.
But in conservative areas, in
Kandahar in the Pashtun south,
lots of families don't
want their children
to go to school, their
daughters to go to school.
Lots of women are still
in the full burqa.
So yeah, I think from
a Western perspective,
it's hard to say there's
been too much improvement
for the situation for
women in Afghanistan,
but there have been incremental
and concrete changes, I think.
Sorry, the first part
of your question?
AUDIENCE: Have there been any
opinion polls from Afghanistan
to see what the Afghans think
about the US involvement
and if they still want us there?
JOSHUA PARTLOW:
You see that people
in places that are changing
from government control,
or the Taliban's
coming in, or they're
worried about a change like that
in the local power structure,
I mean, you talk to
Afghans and yeah,
they want the American
military back to protect them,
to keep things the
way they were, not
have a change in local power.
But I think broadly
speaking, Afghans
aren't happy with the
US military presence.
At least, they aren't
happy with them
in their homes on these
operations, doing night raids,
and arresting people, and
holding Afghans in US jails.
I always sensed that,
I guess, living there,
but then I did a story
once, where I went around
to the Friday sermons
in the mosques,
and I heard the
preachers giving their
giving their sermons
to the people.
And these were
mainstream, many of them
government-funded, mosques, just
the average cleric's opinion
about the week's events.
And I was just stunned by how
anti-American everything was,
describing people, the US
soldiers, as infidel crusaders
and it's our responsibility
as regular Afghans
to rise up against them.
So that opinion is
definitely out there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Could you paint
the most optimistic picture
about the future of Afghanistan
and tell us how to do it?
How to implement it?
Reason being, I mean,
look, a lot of these things
are pretty depressing,
to be honest.
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: And in the Middle
East, in other countries too,
it seems it would be
interesting to know what
would need to happen to fix it.
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah.
I guess I would just go back
to what I touched on before.
There needs to be a political
agreement between the groups
fighting in Afghanistan
and the government
to settle these things
diplomatically and peacefully.
And there are
obviously going to be
opposition groups and ethnic
rivalries that will exist,
and there's a long history
of that in Afghanistan.
But I think a relatively
peaceful resolution
to the conflict
is the first step.
What's going on in
Syria, what's going on
in Iraq, the spread of ISIS--
that's a whole other ball
game right now.
And that's a whole other
concern for the United States,
for Europe, that's
not going to be,
unfortunately, changing, I
don't think, any time soon.
Yeah, I mean,
what's happened when
I got to Iraq in 2006, the rise
of groups like Al Qaeda in Iraq
and then ISIS and these
shock waves that got
set off from the Iraq war
and the invasion there,
I think they've gone a
lot farther than anyone
expected they would.
I wish I could be a little
more optimistic, but--
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry
to sound pessimistic.
Is there a more likely
scenario say, 10 years out,
than the Taliban
have complete control
and it's in some
kind of state that's
not far off from the year 2000,
given when we exit, what forces
are there, really,
to counter things
like their military strength?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah, I think
it's definitely a possibility.
The Iraqi Army and police
have received billions
of dollars and tons of training
from many different countries
over the last 15
years, and they're also
very battle-tested.
They're people who are not
going to necessarily just desert
at the first sign
of trouble coming,
and a lot of these
people-- not everyone,
but a lot of people
involved-- are
fighting because they do
believe in the direction
of the government and they
think that's the better
alternative than the Taliban.
So I think the security
forces, they're well seasoned
and they can protect this
government in certain areas.
And I think with
things going their way,
with maybe other countries
supporting the Taliban less,
somehow that their strength
diminishing in some ways,
I think it's possible this
government can survive.
I think one of the huge
problems right now,
again, is whether
this government will
agree to work together.
I mean, it's a
coalition government
of different ethnic groups, and
they had formed this coalition
with some conditions, that some
changes, reforms would be made,
and the deadline
for those reforms
is this month and none
of them have been met
and so people are threatening
to withdraw from the government.
So if major ethnic factions
leave the government,
I don't think it's
possible to really have
it survive very much longer.
Because the security forces and
the leadership of the security
forces have been some of these
minorities, like the Tajiks,
and the Uzbeks, and
the Hazara leadership
have been important to keeping
the military and police force
fighting for the government.
So there are a lot of risks
out there right now for sure.
AUDIENCE: When the US first
arrived in Afghanistan we
were trying to replace the
opium production with wheat.
Was that successful?
I'm assuming it wasn't.
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah, no,
that wasn't successful.
There were some
programs early on where
they tried to buy up the
opium crop, poppy crop,
from all the farmers as a way
to keep them having some income
and then destroying the crop.
But that wasn't successful.
They've tried eradication.
That hasn't been successful.
It still produces the
majority of the world's opium
and heroin, Afghanistan.
And it's still the
funding source that
drives a lot of the insurgency.
Both the Taliban makes
money off of opium
as well as the powerful members
of the Afghan government.
So when I was there, the people
in this family, the opium trade
was always in the background.
The United States
for a while was
fixated on whether they
could they could find out
whether the president's brother
was a drug trafficker or not,
and spent a lot of hours
and a lot of people
investigating that question
and were ultimately never
able to find any evidence.
But there was a lot of
smoke and a lot of suspicion
that he somehow
helped, basically,
the trucks keep moving
and that sort of thing.
So yeah, I mean, the opium
trade is still alive and well
in Afghanistan.
AUDIENCE: I'm not quite
sure how to ask it,
but was there pushback on
trying to get this published?
Was there any issue with that?
And secondly, are you
working on something else?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: No,
there wasn't really.
There wasn't really pushback.
There was not as much
access, sometimes,
to the family members as
I had hoped when I began.
Some people didn't
want to be involved.
The president has six
brothers and one sister.
A lot of them left
during the Soviet War
and lived in the United States.
One of the brothers,
Mahmoud, owned
a restaurant, the Helmand
on Telegraph Hill,
here in San Francisco, until
it got destroyed by a boulder
during a landslide.
They set up a successful chain
of restaurants in Baltimore,
in Boston, in Chicago.
And they were living this
immigrant successful life
when September 11
happened, and then they
went back to Afghanistan and
got involved in the politics
and the businesses of the war.
So their lives changed
dramatically on September 11.
And some of them, one of
the more colorful members
of the family, Hashmad,
who I mentioned
earlier, he had this private
zoo and he had the dogfighting
pit in his mansion
in the home village,
he was suspicious of
me coming and spending
too much time with him,
I think, because it
was like Game of Thrones,
in a sense, with him.
I mean, he was really reaching
for the mantle of family power.
And so he had been
the real striver
who felt left out
of the family power
and was trying to gain that.
And he ultimately ended
up getting blown up
as well by a suicide bomber.
And so several of the people
I wrote about in this book
ended up dying
during the process.
So--
AUDIENCE: And are you
working on something else?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Something else?
Well, right now I'm the
Mexico correspondent
for the Washington Post.
So I live in Mexico City and I'm
covering Latin America, Central
America, some in South America.
So I've been occupied
on that lately.
So I haven't started
another book yet.
AUDIENCE: What was life like
living in Iraq and Afghanistan
as a journalist?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah,
they were very different.
Iraq, I got there in 2006
when it was the height
of the sectarian violence.
Sunnis and Shiites were killing
each other left and right.
People were moving to
be in neighborhoods
with their different sect.
We lived in a heavily fortified
house in central Baghdad.
At the time, I think there was
a staff of at least 30 Iraqis
working for the Washington
Post, whether it was drivers,
or security guards,
or translators,
or stringers in different
parts of the country.
And it was a much
harder place to work,
because you were
constantly calculating
the risks of going
to a certain area,
and you were living a little
bit more like a prisoner,
or traveling with
the US military
and covering their actions.
In Kabul, I mean, I
loved living in Kabul.
I thought it's a
fascinating city.
It's beautiful in a lot of ways.
It's a kind of stark beauty.
It's ringed with mountains
and it's a valley city.
I think it's 6,000 or
7,000 feet elevation.
There's wood smoke and still
muddy streets and people
in donkey carts and little
kids waving these cans of smoke
to ward off the
evil eye to cars.
It's very exotic
and very different.
And you can still
imagine them living
as 1,000 years ago in a similar
fashion in a lot of ways.
But also they have this
ruggedness in the sense
that they've lived through
so much horrible suffering.
There are places I've
been, like in Islamabad,
for example, in Pakistan,
where I felt like people
were looking at you.
And as a foreigner, it
was a little threatening
and I was worried
about where I was going
and who was watching me.
In Afghanistan, they have this
joyful sort of hopefulness,
despite all the
troubles, and they're
welcoming to foreigners.
There have also been
attacks on foreigners,
so maybe it's gotten
worse over the years.
But at least when
I first got there,
there, I lived in a group
house with other aid workers,
and diplomats, and
journalists, and there
were a lot of ex-pats at the
time when I first got there.
Now there are less.
AUDIENCE: Is the royal family
completely out of the picture
at this point?
And secondly, does Afghanistan
as a political unit matter
to the Afghans?
Or is that a construct
that the West buys into?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Yeah, right.
The royal family is not
too much in the picture.
Some of the members
of the family
were allowed to live in
the presidential palaces
as a courtesy.
I believe that the king
passed away in 2007.
Or maybe earlier
than that, 2004.
He had ruled for
decades until the '70s,
when he was overthrown.
So they are
respected as a family
but they don't have too
active a role in politics.
As far as the construct?
Yeah, I mean, I definitely
think to a large degree
the government is seen
as a Western construct.
I mean, I write in
here about the efforts
to fashion the National
Security Council in the palace.
And ISAF, the US military,
created these detailed flow
charts about how decision
making should take place
and whose committee
meeting and who
had to go to which
subcommittee meeting
and who had to brief who.
And the Afghans just
looked at this stuff
like, "we're not going
to do it this way.
We have our own way of doing it.
We'll all sit around and
talk about it and decide.
And the foreigners won't be
in the room when we decide."
So there's that aspect of it.
I think they see
it as a construct,
but also it's also a predatory
government in a lot of ways.
So at a local level,
police will demand bribes.
Or to get anything done,
if you have a legal case,
you're going to have to
pay the prosecutor a bribe.
You're going to have
to pay the judge.
You're going to have to
pay everyone involved.
So people are
infuriated with that.
A lot of the
sympathy, I think, you
see for the Taliban's
manner of justice
is because it's just
simpler and they get rid
of all that red tape.
AUDIENCE: Is there a partition
that would make sense?
Or do people talk
about a partition
along ethnic or tribal--
JOSHUA PARTLOW: Not the
way in Iraq that I saw.
There's a lot of
nationalism in Afghanistan,
and people are proud
to be Afghans and proud
of their history
and their heritage
as repelling foreign
occupiers for generations.
And there are areas
of the country,
predominately the
Tajiks and the Uzbeks
in the northern
part of the country
and the Pashtuns in the
southern part of the country,
but there was never any
serious talk about partition,
at least when I was there.
AUDIENCE: Could you
give your opinion
on if the foreign
aid dollars that
go there get spent not on
military and on security
but rather on
economic development,
would there be any
chance it would be easier
to stabilize the country?
Because of a lot of this talk
is just about security forces
this or that and military
involvement and what not.
But what if they got Starbucks
and these kinds of things?
Would that help?
JOSHUA PARTLOW:
Yeah, well, I mean,
there has been a lot of that
tried, and a lot of that
has succeeded over the years.
I mean, the development
in Kabul in particular
and the other major
cities is pretty
amazing in a certain way.
I mean, there was maybe
one or two radio stations
when the war started.
There's now a
flourishing media market,
TV stations, radio stations.
There's access to the
internet, cell phones,
access to the outside world
and other ways of thinking.
And the economic
development, there
have been big projects in
mining and agriculture.
What the US military
tended to do often
was flood these little
villages, pay everyone
in a village to dig a ditch,
these day labor projects.
Or they have a
karez system, which
is an underground
irrigation system,
or to dredge those
out and clean those.
And that's just good
for a couple weeks
or however long
the program lasts,
and then people are
back in the same boat.
There have been major advances,
I guess, in the road network
in Afghanistan.
That's changed a lot.
The infrastructure is
better than it was.
I mean, definitely
poverty is rampant.
The economy is ripe for
other projects and for jobs.
And that's what people
care about most.
But there's been a
lot of money wasted.
This aid money
comes in and it gets
filtered through so
many different levels
of the government.
And a school that should
cost $1,000 to build
ends up costing $1
million because so many
different contractors
along the way take a cut.
And then it falls
apart because they
used materials that were
shoddy or weren't appropriate
to the local weather conditions.
There's been a million stories
of squandered aid money.
So a lot of the record
is that kind of stuff.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
from your perspective
as a foreign journalist
working in Afghanistan,
did you see a big contrast
between how media was covering
foreign news, especially
the West, and the West's
interaction with Afghanistan?
Was there a big contrast
between how you were covering it
and how Western
media covered it?
JOSHUA PARTLOW: You mean
other European journalists
would cover Afghanistan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, European
and American news
versus Afghanistan
local news coverage.
JOSHUA PARTLOW: I didn't see
a huge difference, I guess.
I mean, we were all
covering the same stories.
I mean, you go to the
press conferences,
it would be 10
foreign correspondents
and 50 Afghan reporters.
So they had a great, really
vibrant media system,
and they were all over all
the battles, all the scandals.
So I think I didn't
see a huge perspective.
For example, I
live in Mexico now
and I see a bigger difference
between just the way
Mexican media approaches
covering the government.
There are some stand-out
examples of investigative work,
but for the most
part, you don't really
get beyond the surface
layer of the government,
and the PRI there is very
good at keeping-- nobody leaks
anything.
There's no real insight into
how the government works
or how the military works.
And I think that's very
different than the United
States.
But the Afghan
reporters were-- I mean,
everything was
just getting going.
It still is just
getting going, in a way.
So there are a lot of
successes, and there's
a lot of great reporting.
And there were
people who-- I think
one difference that
comes to mind now
is that there were people who
had access to, say, the Taliban
or the insurgency in a way that
a foreigner wouldn't often.
Because that's, I think,
the big, great black hole
of the whole Afghan
War, is what is
the Taliban side of this war?
And we see them as
this faceless group,
but they had their whole
history of their leadership
and the decisions
they made, and why
people were fighting for them.
That was not well covered
in the last 15 years.
And so there were some
American exceptions,
but often people go to meet them
and end up kidnapped or killed.
And so it was
Muslim journalists,
Afghan journalists, other
journals from Middle East
often had a better
time accessing them
and telling people
about who they were
and why they were fighting.
Thank you guys so
much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]